at a meeting of the institute for
international economics
former federal reserve chairman paul
volcker and investor george soros took
part
the event is two hours
now that mr volcker has taken his seat
we can begin
let me welcome all of you to this quote
annual seminar that the institute offers
at the annual meetings of the imf and
world bank
i put quotes around that because we
obviously didn't do it last year
though we had scheduled it when the
meetings were postponed and then moved
we did not do it in prague but we did
start it in hong kong back in 1997
held it here the subsequent two years on
each of those occasions paul volcker who
of course is a
very active member of our board of
directors in addition to
all the less important things he does
has been my co-host
and he is in that role today i always
try to
induce him to take the podium as well
and say a few words
and he's going to do that kind of in the
middle of the program
after we start out with a couple of
other presentations
we have altered the program slightly
from the initial invitation that all of
you got a couple of months ago
we always try to leave ourselves a
little flexibility so as to do that in
light of current events
as they develop at the time of the
meetings in this occasion
we think we will break the program down
into two basic parts
the first part we'll ask wither the
world economy
with a particular focus on the
industrial countries
there's obviously much gloom and doom in
the markets
much anxiety about whether the world
economy and the u.s economy within it
are headed for a double dip new
recession corporate governance scandals
and all that
and we want to address those issues in
the first part
of the meeting roughly the first hour
we will then turn to the emerging
markets
and ask what the prospects are there
including what all that
implies for the functioning of the
international financial system
george soros has kindly volunteered to
lead off that part
of the program as some of you know he
has some
very strong ideas about the implications
for the global economy of what's been
happening
in argentina and brazil in particular
and he will lead off the second part of
our program
with an assessment of that part of the
world and some suggestions for what to
do about it
we'll then have a couple of follow-on
comments there and launch
that second part of the discussion we've
tried to structure this
so as to have a good deal of time for
discussion with the audience
questions and comments from others so
that we can have it as a true seminar
rather than just a series of
presentations from up here
so that's the game plan i want to thank
paul in particular for
co-hosting this again with me and once
again
accepting the invitation to make some
introductory remarks
we'll start with mike musa as some of
you know because you were with us
we did the institute's semi-annual
global economic prospects
layout a couple of weeks ago things have
changed even since then
at least in terms of perceptions and
markets and so mike is going to do an
update
of that outlook and tailor it for the
situation that we now face
mike of course was chief economist of
the fund for 10 years
before joining the institute about a
year ago
we're delighted he's with us and he will
make that lead off presentation
the second set of remarks will focus on
japan
particularly in light of events in japan
over the last week or so
the new pko by the bank of japan the
failed bond
auction the cabinet reshuffle overnight
a number of new developments in japan
that raise and underline the question of
whether that economy
is showing any prospect of getting back
on track
or whether by contrast it is floundering
in a state of panic
and likely headed toward financial
crisis
adam posen who of course did our book on
restoring economic growth in japan four
years ago and has continued
to work very intensely and closely on
the japan situation
will make that presentation we'll then
turn to paul volcker
who will make some comments on what he
has heard
talk in particular about the situation
in the united states in light of his
intimate role and participation in
dealing with the corporate governance
and other problems
that have been faced in this country
over the last six months or so
in particular and then we'll open it up
for general discussion
more or less halfway through about 4 30
or so we will then turn to the second
half of the program
with george soros morris goldstein john
williamson on the emerging markets
and try to wrap it all together mike
take it away
well thank you fred
normally at these affairs i stand up
however when paul volcker is on the same
panel as i am i
sit down i won't explain why
my topic is global economic prospects
uh last year on a fourth quarter fourth
quarter basis the world economy
managed barely one percent real gdp
growth on a weeo weighted basis
uh this year global growth will
strengthen to
about three percent fourth quarter to
fourth quarter
the developing countries as a group are
doing pretty well uh about as well as
forecasts last
april with asia turning into somewhat
stronger than expected performance and
latin america weaker
than expected the industrial countries
however this year are not growing as
strongly as i
and most others had expected uh six
months uh
ago uh and because of that the global
growth forecast with the industrial
countries accounting for a little more
than fifty percent of it on a wheel
basis
uh is cut by half a percentage point for
uh this year that reflects a slowdown
in the united states slower than
expected growth which i anticipate this
year will run about three percent
fourth quarter to fourth quarter rather
than four percent anticipated earlier
and slower than expected recovery in
europe
where growth in western europe will be
on a fourth quarter fourth quarter basis
probably about two percent uh rather
than
two and a half percent and if anything
those forecasts are now
shading downward uh modestly if not for
this year
for next year in light of the recent
sell-off in equity markets
since i completed the numerical forecast
ten days ago
the dow jones has sold off a thousand
points uh including another 150 point
drop
uh today uh and while one shouldn't get
too excited about day-to-day movements
in the
the stock market it's certainly not a
positive indicator going forward
other recent indicators do suggest that
the us economy seems to be losing
forward momentum
as we end third quarter but third
quarter gdp
based on strong auto sales and some
significant strength shown in durable
goods orders
will probably be north of three percent
uh but fourth quarter growth now looks
like it's going to be more like
two and a half or two percent we'll get
a better indication uh from the
september employment report
uh as to just how much the weakening has
been on
on a broad basis looking ahead to next
year
i would also probably marginally cut the
u.s forecast at this stage from three
and a quarter to
uh to three the canadian economy has
been doing
better than the us economy will probably
continue to do so mexico has been a
little bit sluggish in picking up
but did turn to positive growth in the
second quarter and so long as the us
economy remains at least
moderate mexico will i think turn to
moderately stronger growth as we move
forward
the situation is uh decidedly worse
in south america where argentina this
year will
gdp will drop probably 15 percent i
think they'll hit
bottom and bounce off of it so three or
four percent growth next year doesn't
seem to me to be
implausible uh for argentina the main
question mark is
brazil i won't focus on brazil uh
morris and and john williams and we'll
talk more about that issue
uh in our second uh section but gdp
growth for latin america as a whole
including a positive performance by
mexico will uh
be probably minus two percent this year
uh and
uh with argentina bouncing off and with
a bimodal forecast for brazil
centered on zero uh i think will grow
two percent or a little bit less year
over year next year but a big
amount of uncertainty about that looking
across
to europe western european recovery has
lagged behind that in the united states
and increasingly the evidence points to
sluggishness
rather than buoyancy particularly in
germany
but also more broadly in
continental uh europe and in contrast to
the united states where
monetary policy remains quite expansive
and the fiscal policy
is also adding significant impetus in
europe
the ecb seems much less inclined to
respond to
the unexpected sluggishness by further
easing
i thought they made a mistake last year
not easing another 75 basis points which
probably would have strengthened growth
this year by
half a percentage point of thereabouts
and could have added a conceivably a
similar amount to gdp growth
next year as well whether we'll get
further action from them
uh remains to be seen the
fiscal effect of slower growth in europe
is about sixty percent
uh seventy percent of the slowdown in
gdp turns up in
in the deficit uh they have very large
fiscal
offset coefficient so when the ecb
complains about the deteriorating fiscal
performance
my view is perhaps mr duisenberg should
look in the mirror
uh in assessing at least one of the
important people who have some
responsibility for
that result
central and eastern europe is recovering
this year but not particularly buoyantly
the polish economy
remains relatively weak minister kolodko
is trying to provide fiscal stimulus
i think he'll get away with it this year
and next year
but poland may have a problem 2004-2005.
the czech republic is also relatively
slow reacting
to the floods in part other
pieces of central and and eastern europe
are doing better russia is growing
around four
a little bit better turkey is recovering
more strongly than
anticipated the hungarian economy and
and others are doing
reasonably well about as well as as was
expected so
growth of three and a half to four
percent this year and next for the
region as a whole is
is uh a plausible uh
forecast turning to asia the japanese
economy
had a sharp recession in 2001
not unexpected because of the continuing
structural weakness in japan
and added to that a very sharp worldwide
recession
not in gdp but in manufacturing and
japan has is the large industrial
economy which has the largest
manufacturing sector
roughly double the importance to the
japanese economy
of manufacturing as to the us economy
not surprising in a global manufacturing
recession
japan also had a recession last year
provided that manufacturing continues to
recover
japan will recover as well but growth
will remain
uh modest adam will comment more about
the specific situation in japan where
he's a little more pessimistic
than i am to put it mildly the rest of
emerging asia has been doing
better than anticipated i thought china
on the official figures
such as they are would grow around seven
looks like they're going to hit
eight on the officially reported numbers
korea is also doing better than
anticipated
as is singapore thailand and malaysia
hong kong remains in the doldrums taiwan
is
a little shaky as well but emerging asia
as a whole
is growing more strongly than
anticipated next year however
the weaker prospect for the industrial
country suggests
that the emerging asian economies other
than china and india which are
relatively insulated from the rest of
the world
will not be quite as buoyant as i had
earlier anticipated
so i'm projecting six percent growth
rather than seven percent growth for
uh you're merging asia other than india
and china
for 2004.
so in summary the global economic
outlook is one
for recovery this year less buoyant than
was originally
uh anticipated and there are risks
to the downside i mentioned the
asset market sell-off which affects the
u.s
particularly but also europe and to some
extent japan
the other major systemic uncertainty uh
with which i'll conclude
is the question of what would be the
impact of possible military action
in uh iraq there
uh i allow a minus one quarter of one
percent
negative impact on global gdp growth
year over year
for 2003. my assumption is that military
action is a high probability
that if it occurs that it will push
world price world oil prices
up above the low twenty dollars per
barrel to the
low to mid thirty dollars per barrel for
approximately three months
and then prices will fall back uh that
would be the principal uh
uh impact that's about one half the
increase in world oil prices for about
half as long as occurred during the gulf
war at the time of the gulf war
the surge in oil prices on that occasion
appeared to knock about one percentage
point
arguably one and a half percentage
points off global growth for 1991
a year uh over year half as much for
half as long
should do about one quarter of the
damage obviously if there's a prolonged
military engagement if there's damage to
oil production facilities
outside of iraq and so forth then the
negative effect
could be more substantial and
more prolonged there are probably some
short-term positive effects in terms of
modest increases in military spending
impacting
the u.s economy there's also the
prospect that if
military action went swiftly and
successfully
we could see a substantial drop in world
oil prices during the course
of uh 2003 which would operate like a
kind of global
uh tax cut uh benefiting uh world growth
during particularly the the second half
of
of uh next year so minus a quarter
percent is a kind of
probabilistic weighted uh average of of
something that might be worse
and together with something that that
might actually be more positive
okay mike thank you adam on japan
as fred mentioned we changed the
talk discussion list for today i was
initially supposed to speak
on long-term issues of macroeconomic
growth
in germany and japan and answer the
question is germany the next japan
you'll now have to wait for my new book
which comes out in a couple months to
get the answer to that but
published by iae so i'm allowed to plug
it today um
let's just go right to the meat of it
japan has decided to make things
interesting over the last couple weeks
so i'd like to just recap what has
happened that is of interest
what is likely to be the way out of the
current mess which we actually have a
higher probability of achieving
i think right now today than we have had
at any time recent
months the unfortunately still high risk
of a crisis scenario following lines
i've previously
set out for people and then some
question following on mike's masterful
scope of the world economy view what
might be the international effects
so first what has actually been going on
in japan
well the boj blinked um
there has been a game of chicken in
japan for the last
year or so between the major responsible
agencies the bank of japan the ministry
of finance and the financial services
agency
everyone pretty much agrees and
certainly everyone outside the japanese
government agrees
that there needs to be a cleanup of bad
loans a return of distressed assets
primarily real estate to the market
a massive and large scale
that's redundant but redundancy here
would be good expansion of monetary
policy for the bank of japan
and some clever management of tax
restructuring
on the fiscal side to smooth this
transitional process
this has not been able to occur for
several reasons but fundamentally
because of this deadlock amongst
government agencies
the boj would say we're not going to
turn on the printing presses until you
do structural reform fix the banks and
promise
us she won't waste the money the
ministry of finance would say
we're not going to promise anything
until the fsa fixes the banks and until
you give us
non-deflation and the fsa would say
banks what banks no problem
this was the standoff uh
coming up on the half year financial
reports as well as coming up on this set
of meetings here at the fund bank
complex the government of japan
particularly the bank of japan got
nervous
they saw that with the nikkei down in
the low nine thousands the cross
shareholdings of the banks would be well
below the levels they could be at
in order to meet basel capital
requirements and there was some concern
that people would pull their money out
rob duggar of tudor investments who
might be in the who's supposed to be in
the audience the moment
has some up to the minute data he shared
with me that indicated some money really
was leaving japan in the last few weeks
something both he and i have been
watching for for some time
anyway the bank of japan a week ago
wednesday i guess
on the 19th proposed that they might
intend to buy stocks directly from the
banks at some point over the next six
months
on the order of 8 trillion yen then
later that was revised down to 3
trillion yen then revised back up to 8
trillion yen
the response initial response of the
koazumi government was to announce that
they would postpone the announcement of
their anti-deflation package
then there was a cabinet reshuffle last
night or rather
yesterday tokyo time last night our time
and it was announced that a person a
number of us like a great deal and
admire greatly
uh the current cabinet and fiscal
minister hazel takanaka has been made
the fiscal cert excuse me the financial
services agency
minister as well so he now has that in
his portfolio
meanwhile we are in a situation where
japanese growth as mike said has been
very low hard hit by manufacturing
very much hit by the decline in u.s
equity prices
very much hit by expectations that
exports to the u.s will be down
in the coming year that's where we sit
and the reason it's interesting is this
is the first time the boj
has publicly called out the fsa for
getting the banks wrong even though
they've been implying it for two and a
half years
and it's the first time they admitted
they could undertake what's called
non-conventional policy
that is buy things other than just
simply
try to cut a zero interest rate
what is the likely effect of all this
well
no questions i'm adam and you can wait
till later we'll be done in a minute
robert
just hold it robert what no robert wait
10 minutes
thank you um so we've got this going on
and the question is what goes on from
here
right now the boj if they buy these
stocks on its own terms they are not
committed to printing any money to
purchase the stocks this would not
constitute a monetary expansion measure
it would just be a swap of jgbs on the
government's balance on the bank of
japan's balance sheet
for outstanding private sector equities
doesn't do anything about deflation
but as certain people point out it
removes the downside risk for the banks
is it still sort of silly because it has
no conditionality on the banks doesn't
change their incentives and is too small
to be even a real recapitalization
since the banks have a exposure in terms
of shareholdings of about 25 trillion
yen
and the largest amount of money involved
would be 8 trillion yet
also the non-performing loan problem
remember is on the order of 100 trillion
yen or 20
of gdp so again this isn't enough to
deal with that
the real question is is this the start
of a deal uh a deal to break this game
of chicken to take care of the four
aspects i already mentioned the fiscal
expansion
to putting bad assets back on the market
the recapitalization of the banks on
strong conditionality
and aggressive measures to fight
deflation
the fact that minister takanaka was just
appointed to fsa strengthens our
conviction that maybe
a deal could be in the making however
everything that occurred in the last
week in the run-up to this appointment
went in the other direction
it was very clear that the bank of japan
did not inform the government of japan
in any way of the surprise announcement
did not coordinate with them
at best they may have made a phone call
to the ministry of finance an hour
before the press conference and say you
might want to look into the legal
implications of us buying stocks
click the performance we saw this
weekend of finance minister chiu akawa
was one that allowed paul o'neill to
lecture him on clarity
i leave that to you to put an
interpretation upon
this is not a government that has really
got its act together
if if as we hope as i seriously hope is
the case
the appointment of takanaka means
koizumi is backing this kind of plan
we could get a deal the type of deal
i've been advocating the type of deal
glenn hubbard from the chair of the
rcea has been advocating in fact the
type of deal for the last month or so
minister takanaka has been advocating
from his last previous lesser post
is one where there's explicit trade you
close a bunch of banks you recapitalize
the remainders
the bank of japan pays for that by
monetizing a certain amount of jgbs
the government of japan responds by
broadening the tax base but doing
short-term tax cuts to manage the
process
and there's a fixed timetable by which
real estate goes back on the market
we can go into details about that if you
want some of you may remember it's very
similar to what i first advocated in
1998 to prevent this mess from happening
now the question is how optimistic
should we be
we'll find out in the next week or so i
don't think it's a time for premature
optimism even if minister takanaka does
the right thing
with the financial services agency he
will in the end be having to impose a
certain amount of restructuring and bank
closures
he will in the end have to dilute the
shares of current
bank shareholders who have behaved
irresponsibly or whose management has
behaved irresponsibly
these are fundamentally contractionary
forces so unless we get the bank of
japan turning on the printing presses
and the government of japan managing the
fiscal situation appropriately
doing the right thing on banks alone
will actually have a contractionary
effect
now pointing that out let me make two
more points very quickly my last three
minutes
one last spring
at the first of our semi-annual forecast
meetings which mike
headlined i presented an ie policy brief
called the looming japanese crisis
and i predicted or forecast that it was
more than likely japan
would tumble into financial crisis by
september 30th of this year
we're off by a couple weeks but
unfortunately it's getting uncomfortable
whether or not i got that right and let
me point out for the record some of my
very
various theme colleagues including mike
and morris are
totally in disagreement with me and
believe japan is four or five years
without crisis to go
until the debt dynamics the public debt
dynamics get too bad
and i think that's a perfectly arguable
position what's really important is to
think about the story of how
things might get out of hand in japan
and that was the story i told and i
think most people buy it
let me recap it it's basically eight
steps
you get an exogenous shock this is in
your packet you get an exogenous shock
which the financial system is too weak
to handle you get non-coordination
between the government agencies
particularly the boj
and the moth leading to market confusion
and inadequate policy response
you get a spike in long jgb rates or
some interruption in the jgb market
as it becomes clear that the government
has to make a decision about an
obligation that's going on its balance
sheet
like pension funds or bank
recapitalization
fourth you get some increased capital
flight from japan or movement of
disintermediation into cash into gold
out of the banking system
fifth the bond agencies downgrade
japanese debt further
sixth the moth control freaks try to run
another pko or price keeping operation
and further diminished liquidity in the
market
seventh yen goes down stocks go down
eighth you get
severe contraction in business
investment and then away you go
now not to be too gloomy here but we're
into step four
the exogenous shock was the perspective
contraction of u.s import demand
and the u.s financial decline the
non-coordination of boj
and the government we've just seen the
spike in long jgb rates the interruption
in japanese government bond markets we
just saw
last friday in the undersubscribed
auction
capital flight as i mentioned has been a
very short-term trend but it has sparked
up in the last two weeks
and moody's has announced they are
moving up the date for reevaluating
japan's credit rating
i am hopeful that the government of
japan and particularly with the bank of
japan being scared enough to have
started this in motion
that they will stop this it is within
their power to do so if they make the
deal we discussed
if they do not and this is where i'll
close we are looking at an unfortunate
international situation mike has given a
very reasonable
baseline forecast and what will happen
to japan and what will happen to the
world economy
however has been the main message of i
think mike's forecast and i think of
these meetings this weekend
it is the industrial country's failure
to grow particularly that of japan and
euroland
that is the main problem facing the
world system right now
if japan were to contract along the
lines of which i've outlined
what you're going to see is essentially
the us having to export
its adjustment to the emerging markets
because japan
and germany and continental europe
simply will not be growing fast enough
to absorb imports
in which case if you think you've got a
globalization backlash now
wait till you see emerging markets
middle classes in korea and elsewhere
who
claim we did everything the imf told us
japan meanwhile gets away with this and
we don't we have to suffer their exports
that will be bad that is a direct
conflict with the g7s interest and
that's why i'm very heartened
that the u.s government particularly
glenn hubbard but also apparently paul
o'neill
have stood up and started putting
pressure directly on japan again the way
the previous administration correctly
did
let me end with a baseball analogy um
people had given up on gaiatsu because
it was basically was only a 333
bet you know in baseball 333 is pretty
good
if you bat zero when you put no pressure
on japan to change
better to go with the 333 so i think for
that
let's all try to be hitters on japan
thank you
adam thank you we'll now turn to
chairman volcker
comments on the us japan corporate
governance
and anything else you might like dude
we're not going to allow the audience to
salt these people first
no we're going to let you assault first
and then we'll let them assault you
as well as them well i will be brief i
let me say i've always thought
as i'm sure all the people here are
aware that one of the characteristics of
fred bergson
is his ability to speak with great
clarity very persuasively never in doubt
i judge from the presentations we've had
that those characteristics now permeate
the staff
generally
now whether they're right or wrong is
another another question when i
hear this about japan i have a certain
sympathy for a statement that was
reported to me i wasn't there by prime
minister rizumi when he was in new york
recently at the council and he was asked
why he didn't deal with all these
banking problems
he said well i've consulted all the
experts half of them tell me if i
do nothing and let this go i'm going to
face an enormous crisis
the other half says if i try to do
something about it i face an enormous
crisis
that leaves me in some doubt as to what
i should do and i
i think they their actions are locked up
based on enormous
i've reflected that now
i don't have much to add about the
business outlook i
i think the united states economy is
growing not as fast as people would like
i think at the moment looks like it will
continue to grow but
it is very heavily dependent upon
consumption and i'm an old man and i
don't understand the younger generation
that consumes all they
earn so consistently whether or not the
stock market's up down and sideways
and so long as that goes on i guess
we'll get a little gross but i get a
little nervous that it's not going to go
on
and i may see some unsustainabilities
in the flow of foreign capital in the
united states
and the sustainability of our current
account deficit
the good news in that respect is that
the rest of the world looks so bad as
they've just described that
the united states still gets a flow of
capital
uh you know i remember that great remark
uh
aphorism of herb sign that that which is
unsustainable won't be sustained
and it's always put in a comforting uh
mo don't worry about it because it'll
take care of itself
uh i always worry about the coral area
that unsustainable things that go on for
too long
will result in a hell of a mess but uh
i'm a little worried about uh that part
of the
scenario and uh
you know there just doesn't seem to be a
lot of strength in in the world economy
has already
has been indicated but on the other hand
it's holding its own
uh one of the reasons i think for lack
of action in japan
is as new as i can see public opinion in
japan has not been terribly upset by the
lack of growth for a decade
apparently have the feeling that they're
pretty well off they've
got among the highest standards living
in the world there isn't all that much
unemployment
if you're employed
don't worry about it enough to break
through all the barriers
political and otherwise to change they
like their society
the way it is now what about the
american society to just switch to
corporate governance which by accident i
am now considered a guru i guess because
arthur anderson came to me in extremis
and asked me to exercise some oversight
corporate governance is an area where in
contrast economics everything is clear
and certain
that a cause and effect is uh is quite
certain
and of course i don't believe that it's
a very complicated area
uh i do think we have
a substantial problem in the united
states
not just with corporate governance but
with economic governance more broadly
including the whole range of
professional
institutions i'd like to think beginning
with investment banks
maybe i could begin with consultants
going through lawyers
going through certainly management
compensation consultants
and more or less ending up with auditors
where there has been a
breakdown of what we would like to think
is
prudent and ethical behavior
now i'm not suggesting that
the really egregious examples we see is
illegal behavior fraudulent behavior of
looting of corporate assets in some
cases is characteristic of business as a
whole
but i do think that boom and bubble
in the stock market and the enormous
amount of money
generated there the enormous
rewards for some people have led to
rhode island greenspan and i think
correctly characterized
in that phrase infectious greed
which led to a lot of people pushing
behavior
to the envelope as the expression goes
in some cases beyond the envelope
whether it is
illegal actually illegal or not
that is a phenomenon i think that is not
uncommon in the midst of or in reaction
to great booms
uh go back to the 1890s or the early
part of this century
the era of the so-called robber barons
go back to the 1920s
the earlier great boom of course led to
anti-trust laws it led in fact to the
federal reserve the
repetitive crisis 1920s you had the sec
investor protection
fdic and and other measures
uh i think this incident is somewhat
comparable although it has not yet had
the effect anyway
of leading to a great and prolonged
depression it may contribute to a
considerable period of sluggishness
however
and it is leading to some reforms
i don't think there is a board of
directors or a chief executive officer
in the united states that hasn't been
somewhat affected in its behavior and
certainly in its worries
from what's been going on or what's been
revealed in recent months
and they are in some sense i'm sure
being more careful than they were before
what is at issue is how long that will
last
memories tend to be short when things go
better
and whether more concrete measures of
reform are needed there's an awful lot
of talk about the responsibility of
directors
and the importance of independent
directors for one thing
i must say when i hear the word
independent directors
in my mind there's a quotation mark
around that word independent
because i don't think uh good and
committed directors are really
independent
apart from the fact that either
appointed by the chief executive or they
have appointed the chief executive
which leads to a certain community of
interest obviously a
board of directors tends to be collegial
it focuses on what they're interested in
as large as strategic issues
and personnel issues but it doesn't come
naturally to take a highly skeptical
oversight view of the corporation
putting themselves in potential conflict
with the chief executive officer or the
chief financial officer
or whoever and we go say well go have a
good independent uh
compensation committee and have a good
independent auditing committee
you put a very heavy burden on these
people
which i'm not sure they're in a position
to discharge frankly with great
effectiveness
where is that compensation committee
that wants to say to their chief
executive officer
that you're doing a good job but we
think in the interest of general good
corporate governance you ought to take
lower pay than the other people in the
other companies
not very many show that how many chief
executive officers say well i want to
take the leadership in
showing that i'm a moral chief executive
why don't you cut my
10 million dollars next year to 5
million
i would suggest that's not going to be a
very common
phenomenon how many directors
are really capable of surveying
and exercising oversight over the
finances of a complicated financial
institution
i was such a director and i felt
incompetent
to do what good corporate government
suggests that
i tried to stay off the auditing
committees and the conversation
committees
but i'll tell you it is a bigger job
than an ordinary director
can accomplish particularly when they're
not
elected for a specific skill and
responsibility in those
areas but the conclusion i draw from
this
is we've got to have some
clearer and more decisive reforms if we
expect the current
atmosphere of responsibility to persist
now a major question here is the role of
the auditor itself the outside auditor
and that's where this crisis in part
started
in connection with enron and the
problems of repeated problems of arthur
anderson
i have i pretty quickly reached the
conclusion
that there is a big structural problem
here
in the diversification of the accounting
institutions
that the actual formal
conflict that got created between doing
a good audit
which involves a degree of skeptical
oversight to say the least
and competing for lucrative consulting
business is real but whether or not
that obvious conflict affected auditing
it is quite clear that accounting firms
decided auditing was a relatively
limited part of their business
their future lay in various forms of
consulting
that is where they would concentrate
their resources their marketing efforts
their talents and the emphasis
on auditing their central function was
lessened it is reflected in a clearly
less disciplined auditing process
than is considered appropriate certainly
these days but would have been
considered appropriate traditionally
for an auditing firm now those problems
have been dealt with
i think potentially effectively by
legislation
and i think legislation was required
these are not the first auditing
problems we've had but the industry has
always fended off any kind of
governmental oversight
they had oversight bodies which the
industry itself or the profession itself
dominated to the point that they had no
embarrassment about reducing the funding
of those oversight bodies
if they appeared to be headed in a
direction they didn't like
so i think this piece of legislation is
really seminal and kind of
completes a a area of government
regulation
in the securities market and in auditing
uh that only started in the
in the 1930s with the sec and the
oversight of the securities industry
itself
how that is implemented is still at
issue a big question but i think the
apparatus is there and
useful so far as corporate governance
itself is concerned
i only will tell you
the conclusions that i arrive at and i
don't think they're a magic answer but i
think they would be helpful over a
period of time
the excesses of executive compensation
which have been so much
commented on and i surely meet any
definition that i know of excesses
is importantly a phenomena in the late
1990s
of fixed price stock options companies
didn't set out
to pay 100 million dollars to their
chief executive
and we have chief executives taking out
and other executives 100 million dollars
in compensation for companies the very
year that the company went bankrupt
i don't think that was any compensation
objective
but it was the result of fixed price
stock options
and when you look at it pretty hard what
do these fixed stock options do they're
supposed to be aligning
as the mantra goes the incentives of
management with stockholders
the results quite clearly are capricious
everybody gets paid the good the bad and
the ugly
when you have a boom in the stock market
when the stock market goes down
that same management will be incented
not at all because all the stock options
are underwater they happen to be the
same people
they probably are working just as hard
and just as effectively as they did when
the stock options were
returning a large amount of money but
where is the incentive
not only that but the incentive can
positively and has been
perverse why
have dividends become almost a lost art
among american corporations
well you know all the investment bankers
will tell you it's a tax matter
we doubly tax dividends which is
certainly true
we have double tax dividends in my whole
lifetime
or practically my whole lifetime i guess
we didn't have the corporate income tax
the same way in the 1930s in fact the
dove
taxation of deadlines was more severe 20
years ago than it is now
did we only discover that in the 1990s
i don't think so what we discovered was
stock options
and if you've got a stock option you
don't pay dividends you buy to back the
stock in the market
because that helps the option and the
dividend doesn't
and anybody tells you that hasn't been a
factor in the lack of pavement of
dividends in
american corporations in the last 10
years i do not think
is accurately reflecting the situation
we also have across the phenomenon often
commented on
on the short termism that this may
induce which is i think reflected in the
behavior where we've had large payoffs
to companies that are on the verge of
bankruptcy or or decline
so what do you do about this there's an
awful lot of talk about expensing stock
options i don't want to get in all that
except to say that i don't think anybody
has a magic formula that everybody will
salute on
i've decided we ought to go about beyond
that
and express a clear policy i don't mean
by legislation but i would like to see
one of the tenants of corporate
governance
that fixed price stock options are not a
preferred or even reasonable member
measure method of
compensation i don't know of anything
reasonable in terms of aligning
incentives that couldn't be better
achieved
by grants of stock by grants of
restricted stock
by shadow stock and other devices that
have
i think different risks and a better
incentive structure than stock options
so that's number one
number two i will be very brief and say
i do think that the age of the imperial
chief executive should be reined in
and subject to better oversight and
discipline than we've had
and i think the advantage is more
continental european and british system
of a non-executive
chairman of the board ought to be again
may not fit every circumstance every
year all the time but as they preferred
method of corporate governance
that would be useful in preventing some
of the excesses that have developed
my only final word and i will make a
transition to our next session
there's a great irony that if we were
talking about this four years ago we
wouldn't be talking about the united
states we'd be talking about all those
corporate governance
failures in the developing world
why didn't they have american gap why
didn't they have a good
american auditing procedures
why didn't they have better corporate
governance
generally why did they have so much
cronyism between the
executives and the directors
i think it's rather a healthy thing that
we have
discovered that maybe there have been
some flaws in our own governance
but i also think it is i don't know how
big an impediment
but it's another little obstacle to
solving the idea
that global financial capitalism is a
good thing for everybody
i retain the view that for no other
reason then technologically that's going
to continue
i think it should continue theoretically
it should be a good thing
for growth and stability objectively i
don't think we can
show that case empirically at the moment
on the financial side i think we can on
the trade side
and i don't think this recent behavior
of american corporate governance has
helped
the good news is of course it's all out
in the open i sometimes think we ought
to thank
worldcom and enron and adelphia and
so forth and so on because it's only
with those extreme
egregious
difficulties errors in corporate
management that we really inspire reform
and i think we are beginning to get it
paul thank you very much and before i
open to the floor i'd like to just
ask you one question myself it sounded
to me
from your analysis of the impotence
of corporate boards and independent
directors
that you were really raising a
fundamental question about the whole
system
of boards of directors as
representatives of shareholders
does that over interpret what you're
saying i said oh i don't know everybody
other system and i
certainly are not raising a question
about boards or directors
i do have a kind of idea in the back of
my head which
i have not thought is quite ready for
prime time i'm not sure
it's your seminar prime time or not uh
fred but it's for intellectual
brainstorming
well i'll intellectually brainstorm this
one uh
i think the really critical committee
you're talking about and everybody's
talking about is the auditing committee
and that is the most difficult area for
big complicated companies it's not
you know a traditional straightforward
industrial company it's probably
manageable for small companies that may
be manageable
but when you're auditing one of these
big complicated
multinational industrial companies
and particularly financial companies you
got a problem
and can any uh you know
you got
13 14 person board of directors they
shouldn't be bigger than that you pick
them for a variety of backgrounds you
pick some old civil servant or
central banker because you want that and
you got a couple of
ceos on it you've got a sociologist on
it you've got
you know certain social needs that have
to be met and then you say well you know
now we've got to have an auditing
committee
how do you man the auditing committee uh
these people haven't been picked
ordinarily for particular expertise
certainly not three or four not
not a quarter of the board in this area
nor do they have the time to do
the kind of job that's necessary
so what do you do well there are a
number of things i think you can do to
strengthen it the more extreme thing
which that doesn't strike me is so
extreme
is just suppose you had the stockholders
elect the auditing committee separately
and you
then were electing say three people
you're electing them presumably because
of their particular capability
in auditing and financial analysis
you are making clear to them that they
have to spend the time
necessary meet as frequently as possible
do the homework that's required
and the responsibility is on them and
they i guess would report to the regular
board of directors
but here you have a capability and a
sense of responsibility that could not
be escaped because that's why they're
elected
now maybe you just do that by electing
some
members of the regular board as members
of the auditing committee at the same
time they're elected to the board
but some mechanism of that sort seems to
me might be helpful
very interesting floor is open for
questions to any of the panel yes let me
ask
a question to introduce him or herself
and then
fire away and aiming at an individual if
you wish
i'm uh korean packer from bank one uh
speaking of sustainability uh i'd like
to ask a question from both mr walker
and fred
about the u.s current account and the
dollar i know that's one of
fred's favorite topics paul's too
paul well i'll go first and be uncertain
and then fred will tell you
more precisely i
you know i've got an old record of
worrying about u.s current account
deficits and i want to put this on the
record first i
uh back when i was in the federal
reserve and our deficits began getting
pretty big in the 1980s
i clearly remember the staff bob
solomon's successes presenting an
analysis said they're going to get
bigger whatever year was they're going
to get bigger next year and they're
going to get still bigger the
following year and they're already
pretty big and my astute comment was
along the lines of herb stein don't
worry about it nobody's going to finance
that bigger deficit and it's not going
to happen well it happened
and it's happened now for a good many
years
and how long could it last uh
you know the irony of it in a way is
that it will be most vulnerable when the
rest of the world is feeling better
because then they want to invest at home
and they won't be so eager to invest in
the united states particularly when the
outlook in the united states a little
more cloudy than it was
i don't know that's the good news or the
bad news but the opposite is
there isn't any sign of it getting that
much better in the rest of the world
so it is possible despite
any dent and confidence that the
corporate governance and other things
and the performance of the economy
may have put in the equation i am in no
position to say that i couldn't go on
for another year another two years but
i also think the longer goes on and the
bigger it gets
the more difficult the ultimate
adjustment will be
just so everybody knows the numbers uh
the second quarter number
came in with the current account deficit
at an annual rate of 520 billion dollars
in excess of five percent of gdp the
sharp increase in the deficit in the
second quarter
cut u.s gdp growth more than in half
in fact if that had not happened there
might not be quite as much doldrums now
about
lousy u.s growth because domestic demand
grew about five percent in the first
quarter three percent in a second looks
like four percent in the third
that big dip in the second quarter would
not have occurred except for the big
further jump in the external deficit
when you combine the current account
deficit with our own capital exports
the u.s has to import gross levels of
foreign capital to the tune of about
four billion dollars every working day
so the numbers are big and i'm of course
in the camp that says
it ain't sustainable however let me give
you a quick report
on a conference we had on us here at the
institute just a week ago last tuesday
we had a full day conference on the
dollar a bigger group even than this
with i think every viewpoint conceivable
represented
economic pools of thought different
countries etc etc
there were four main conclusions the
first conclusion which was unanimous not
a dissent
was that the dollar was substantially
overvalued the current account deficit
had to be reduced sharply both for
desirability reasons
in terms of a number of economic and
other objectives and for sustainability
reasons
second there was substantial
disagreement about the amount by which
the dollar had to come down
the traditional analyses like john
williamson's my own
holding the net international investment
position constant as a fraction of gdp
all that suggested current account
deficit should be cut roughly at half
dollar trade weighted exchange rate need
to come down 20
25 percent there was a school of thought
however
a minority but strong school of thought
which suggested that the
sharp continuing increase in judas and
u.s productivity growth
particularly combined with the sharp
declines
in european and japanese productivity
growth in the last half decade or so
amounted to a de facto alternate
alternative to dollar depreciation so
that
the actual dollar depreciation that
would be required to
restore equilibrium was maybe only about
10 to 15 percent
in short that the u.s might be able to
sustain external deficits
on the order of three to four percent of
gdp not the more traditional two
two and a half the third view which i
thought was one of the most interesting
was that the geographical distribution
of any u.s adjustment might be different
than we have traditionally thought
when you think of the plaza agreement or
traditional kind of g7 coordination
efforts
explicit or implicit you tend to think
of a u.s
deficit reduction being mainly mirrored
in reductions in surpluses in japan and
europe
there was quite a debate of course about
japan whether the yen in fact should go
up or should go down
whether their deficit whether they're
huge and growing surplus
should come down at all or in fact be
permitted to give them at least a little
growth
but even allowing for that there was a
strong view that any substantial u.s
correction would have to be mirrored
largely by
sharp adjustments in the canadian dollar
the chinese renminbi
and probably other east asian currencies
like korea
there was in fact even a substantial
school of thought
in the discussion some using the term
manipulation some not
that there needed to be a much more
aggressive and active imf
effort to monitor the behavior of
individual
surplus countries piling up reserves and
impeding adjustment of the u.s current
account position
fingers of course pointed at japan which
has very overtly and aggressively
tried to weaken the yen and the exchange
markets nobody denied nobody
defended that practice all called on
japan to desist on that front
but others also suggesting that china by
piling up
over 300 billion dollars of reserves
maintaining a fixed rate
was in fact essentially competitively
undervaluing
the renminbi and should be called upon
as part of an international adjustment
to let the rate fluctuate with some
lesser degree
of zeal same points made about korea
and some other east asian countries so
there was some difference in view
as to the geographical distribution on
policy
there was unanimity as i say that japan
should desist from
trying to talk down or actually drive
down the yen and
impede the kind of adjustment that most
people felt was needed
uh some people recalled that over the
first half of this year
the dollar exchange rate had declined by
a trade weighted average of five to ten
percent and a little more
against the euro and the yen that
exchange rate correction many
people noted was perfectly gradual and
perfectly orderly
and had no noticeable adverse effects
certainly on the u.s economy
or international financial stability
that led to the inference that maybe
another six to twelve months of similar
gradual
orderly correction was what the doctor
ordered do it now
while it would have very little if any
inflationary or interest rate impact on
the u.s
do it now while europe and japan are
relatively weak
so there was unlikely to be a sharp run
out of dollars on a hard landing
in short do the correction now sooner
rather than later next question
bob solomon
fire patience is always rewarding
adam was talking when talking about
japan said the bank of japan
was proposing to buy stock from the
commercial banks
and i don't know what you mean you mean
to buy stock issued by the banks or do
you mean open market operations you mean
i mean to buy from their holdings of
non-financial firm equity so in the k
rats who sense
not bonds just equities that are held by
the
merchant banks meant japanese announced
a week ago the bank of the bank of japan
announced that someone said
market operations no it's not really a
form of a market
i mean in a literal sense yes but open
market operation
usually conveys the idea that they're
undergoing monetary expansion or
contraction
the bank of japan has implied and the
markets have responded as though they do
not expect the bank of japan
to print any money to do this they
expect them to take
currently outstanding jgbs they already
own and swap them for the bon
for the stocks there will be no monetary
effect of this policy
question back here
a question for mr volcker on
next steps on governance
i guess one of the peculiar things about
the crisis we saw was
the multiple layers of failure
in governance of corporations and
several commentators have pointed out
how
it wasn't just the stock analysts or the
lawyers the auditors
it was everybody involved that somehow
was asleep at the switch
and a great deal of thought and
a fast action has gone into reforming
different parts of the equation with the
new york stock exchange and nasdaq
developing governance rules with of
course sarbanes-oxley
and the concern about analysts and and
their independence
but one area that i i'm not sure so much
attention has been given to
is what it's reasonable to expect
institutional investors to contribute
by way of being good owners of
corporations
in some respects you would hope that the
owners
of the shareholders of companies would
be the best
position people to provide leadership in
how companies are run
and yet we've seen through different
investment strategies
a great deal of diversification for
example and a typical
fund and its ownership a reluctance to
become active shareholders
uh what can we do about that
well i don't know this has been
discussed and i haven't seen any
clear-cut
answer but let me let me just
question one of the words you use you
say all these people have been asleep
well that's one way of looking at it i
think another way of looking at it is
they were too wide awake
they were too eager to find ways around
the rules and how to cut corners and
they were very much alive i'm afraid
they were just alive in the wrong
direction
the role of
the institutional investor is an
interesting one
you know the investment banks themselves
have become large institutional
investors
they are conflicted right off the bat
don't look to them
any activity in this area uh
repeatedly we have discovered i think
that the typical mutual fund company
is you may not think they're conflicted
they are
the corporations are their client they
want to sell them pension business they
want to
get their 401k plans they're not about
to become active critics
of their corporate clients actual or
potential that leaves a relatively small
ban perhaps of state investment offices
tiaa craft one or two others that have
had a continuing interest in this area
and have in fact brought pressure for
certain types of reform but it hasn't
been very consistent hasn't been quite
on top of the issues that have
come out you know one of uh
it's symptomatic i think i got
involved in encouraging international
accounting standards and
for obvious reasons in a globalized
world you ought to have consistent
international accounting standards
and this is financed basically by
passing the hat among
uh business interests and actually some
governmental interests around the world
who are quite successful in this renewed
effort of getting financing now one
industry group in the united states and
elsewhere
that tended to shut us down completely
was investment companies
and you would say my god the investment
companies must be the ones who have the
most to
benefit all i know is empirically they
were the slowest to
to contribute and most of them are not
contributed either as an industry or
individually
and when i press some of them and this
is maybe typical of
the attitudes in the market they say
well we can best our analysts
and we think we understand all these
complications of accounting better than
other people why should we make it easy
for our competitors
not a very far-sighted i think
approach but apparently a persuasive one
okay thanks to this panel
i will ask mike and adam to step down
george morris and john to step up and we
will
transit to the developing countries paul
will stay up here
and add his thoughts to that
part of the dimension as well
the same old crew seems to be getting
older we need something
i can't deny
okay the next set of topics is the
impact on the world economy of the
emerging markets the outlook for them
both in the immediate sense of key
countries brazil
in particular but also
whether events in the emerging markets
suggest systemic problems that raise
broader questions about the future of
the world economy
the same way paul volcker has been
raising questions about corporate
governance systems
and whether they affect our broader and
more underlying outlook for the global
economic order
george soros as always has some
provocative thoughts on that broader set
of questions
and he will begin our discussion of this
segment of the program
we'll then turn immediately to morris
goldstein and john williamson to talk in
more detail about
brazil and latin america and maybe to
make a comment or two
on george's ideas george thank you thank
you i appreciate this opportunity
to address you because i have news for
you
the international financial system is
already failing
in the sense that it doesn't provide an
adequate flow of capital
to countries that need it and qualifi
qualify for it the markets are very good
in sucking up savings from all over the
world
but they are failing in their task of
pumping it out
to the periphery this qualifies
as news because the problem is not
generally
recognized it's generally believed
that financial markets are very
efficient in allocating capital both
domestically and internationally
that is not the case the facts
speak for themselves the united states
runs a chronic current account deficit
that is now around 5
242 billion for the first half of this
year as it was mentioned earlier
this is an enormous amount that allows
the united states
to serve as the motor of the world
economy
at the same time brazil which has
followed sound economic policies has a
primary budget surplus of three and
three-quarters per cent
and a large and growing trade surplus is
unable to refinance its debt at
acceptable rates
as you know brazil's dollar denominated
that
today yields 25 percent and the one year
real note that pays nearly 30 percent
with domestic inflation at seven percent
at these rates brazil is insolvent
other less developed countries that have
been
faithfully following imf prescriptions
are also in trouble because of depressed
prices for their primary products
lack of access market access
in developed countries or lack of
domestic demand
overall there has been a reverse flow of
capital
from the periphery to the center ever
since 1997.
yet the international monetary
authorities
refuse to recognize that there is a
systemic problem
let alone that the system is broken down
they continue to believe that market
discipline is the only
way to correct the prevailing imbalances
i contend that this belief is false on
two counts
first financial markets don't
are inherently unstable second
the international financial system is
lopsided
in favor of the center and to the to the
detriment
of the periphery on the first point
financial markets don't tend towards
equilibrium
because they try to discount a future
which is contingent
on the behavior of the markets
themselves
it's now recognized that this can lead
to
multiple equilibria but we are still in
denial
about the implication that financial
markets
can't be left to their own devices
in practice of course they have never
been left
to their own devices and that is what
has made
the international financial system so
lopsided
because it's the rich countries at the
center
that are at the in charge of the system
with the united
states more equal than the others when
their own economies or financial
institutions get into trouble
the authorities intervened forcefully
but countries they can't borrow in the
international markets
in their own currency don't have the
same powers
they have to turn to the imf and the imf
is more concerned with preserving the
stability of the system
than with enabling developing countries
to avoid
recessions as a result countries that
have access
to the international markets can pursue
counter-cyclical policies while
countries that have to turn to the imf
can't until recently
imf rescue programs were designed to
enable the data countries
to meet their obligations and it was the
taxpayers of the debtor countries like
mexico
who had to pay pick up the tab this may
have been unfair
but it did keep money flowing to the
periphery
after the emerging market crisis of 97
98
there was a 180 degree turn in imf
policies the crisis was attributed
not to the instability of the financial
markets and the lopsidedness of the
system
but to the so-called moral hazard
introduced by the imf bailouts
and this has led to a u-turn from
bailouts to bail-ins
and private sector burden sharing
as a result the moral hazard has in fact
been eliminated
but the risks of investing or lending to
emerging markets
have greatly increased these risks are
now fully reflected in market prices
and that is the source of the current
problem
the problem doesn't manifest itself as a
systemic crisis
but rather as a crisis in individual
countries
and a chronic system-wide reverse flow
of capital from the periphery to the
center
left and left unattended the situation
is bound to deteriorate
and it may well culminate in a systemic
crisis
now it should not be beyond our capacity
and ingenuity
to forestall such a development but the
first requirement
is to understand the problem and that
has not yet happened
we have yet to admit that the situation
in brazil
is not just a brazilian problem but
a systemic problem what could be done
i shall stick to general principles
because the actual measures
can't be designed by an outsider they
will require
elaborate negotiations and preparations
in the broadest terms we must rebalance
the system
to create a more level playing field
the risk reward ratio for lending and
investing
has shifted too far against the
periphery
there's nothing wrong with imposing
market discipline
on countries that follow unsound
policies or don't respect
property rights or human rights but if
we relied on market discipline alone
countries that follow sound policies
would still remain
at a disadvantage we must therefore
complement market discipline with
measures
designed to create a more level playing
field
countries that qualify ought to be
empowered
to pursue counter-cyclical policies and
they ought to have access
to a lender of last resort
let me explain what this would mean for
first for brazil
and then for the system as a whole in
the case of brazil
we are dealing with a mark with a market
failure
which requires the intervention of a
lender of last resort
with a primary budget surplus of three
and three-quarters percent
brazil could pay seven percent more
than its growth rate without a
deterioration
in the debt to the gdp ratio
that means that the maximum real
interest rate
that would be sustainable is about 10
percent
yet the current interest rates are above
20 at those rates
brazil is heading for an eventual
bankruptcy
capital is fleeing brazil because
capitalists don't like lula
and financial markets have the power to
indulge
in self-fulfilling prophecies if the
international authorities
can't find a way to ensure that credit
is available
at or below 10 they can't expect brazil
to meet its obligations and that would
be a terrible blow
both for brazil and the system
where there is a political will there is
a way
if the 30 billion
doesn't do the trick that then the imf
could use other tricks for instance
the central banks of the united states
europe
japan and britain could accept brazilian
paper at their discount window
with the imf guaranteeing the central
banks against market risk at current
prices
that would give a tremendous boost to
the market and drastically reduce
interest rates and if the move were not
sufficient to reduce them below 10
percent
the guaranteed prices could be increased
but only with a suitable haircut
in this way the risk taken by the imf
could be kept within bounds naturally
this would be conditional on the
brazilian
government continuing to abide by the
imf
agreement if the operation is successful
the imf guarantee would not be invoked
at all
what i am proposing is innovative
but it's appropriate to the
circumstances and it would also
constitute a useful precedent
in effect it would endow the 30 billion
that the imf is willing to lend
brazil with a tenfold leverage
if for some technical reason my proposal
proved impractical
it would be up to the authorities to
come up with something better
one alternative would be to have a large
increase in the imf
package itself but that may require an
increase in the imf's own resources
which would take too long to arrange
unfortunately the scheme i'm proposing
goes beyond the imagination of the
financial authorities in washington
not to mention the political will of the
imf's
shareholders but let me emphasize that
if they fail to address the problem
the consequences could be disastrous for
instance how would the brazilian
default affect mexico and what is
the or the effect on the international
commercial banks that are already
fleeing
the periphery because they the
shareholders are punishing them for
their exposure
it was possible to let argentina
go down the drain because of the way
the abandonment of the currency board
was handled
but to leave brazil without the lender
of last resort
would mean the bankruptcy of the system
now addressing the broader system-wide
problem
some ways have to be found to stimulate
domestic-led growth
in the periphery countries countries
that are following sound microeconomic
policies
don't derive sufficient economic
benefits from it
this generates political discontent
that could have adverse consequences
that go beyond
the economic sphere at present
the united states serves as the motor of
the global economy
but a chronic current account is
unsound unfair and as we
as we've discussed earlier unsustainable
in the long run
more more urgently the motor is
currently sputtering it would be
beneficial to all parties concerned to
get
another motor started to this end
i have proposed an annual issues of
special drawing rights
that the rich countries would donate for
international
assistance this is a proposal whose time
has come because the world economy is
hovering
on the brink of deflation
until recently globalization unfolded
against the
background of a global boom now we are
experiencing a global bear market the
developed
economies are faltering and we need
to inject stimulus
in the less developed part of the
world central bankers are viscerally
opposed
because the sdr donation scheme
uh involves uh
basically the creation of new money
but that is exactly what makes it uh
attractive at the present time it would
activate resources that are currently
idle
and it would benefit both donors and
recipients
it would also help to reduce the
increasing inequality
between rich and poor countries
now i realize that this proposal is
outside the purview of the authorities
does that mean that the proposal is
unrealistic
i think it means that the authorities
are asleep at the switch
thank you thank you george provocative
as promised
uh we'll turn to morris goldstein first
then john williamson
well good afternoon it's a great uh
pleasure to be here
uh there are two questions i think
before the house in this session
one is whether brazil is likely to
undergo a major debt crisis within
say the next six months nine months 15
months
something like that my short answer to
that question is yes
unless things change unexpectedly and
dramatically for the better
second would future financial crises and
emerging economies be reduced in
frequency
and severity by g7 guarantees or
purchases of emerging market bonds
my short answer there is no what we need
instead is more conservative fiscal and
foreign borrowing strategies and better
debt management
on the part of emerging economies
themselves along with reform of imf
lending practices to make debt
sustainability
a key condition of imf conditionality
if you look at four of the most
prominent crisis or near crisis
economies
argentina brazil uruguay and turkey the
striking characteristic they have in
common is they have too much public
or external debt in argentina on the eve
of its crisis the ratio of external debt
to merchandise exports was about 500
percent
there have been very few cases of
countries
moving from debt ratios like that to
more moderate ones without major
restructurings
over the past 20 years indeed i could
only find one chile
in brazil the ratio of external debt to
merchandise exports is about 400 percent
and net public debt is your share of gdp
is over 60 percent
in uruguay we're looking at merchandise
external debt to merchandise exports of
about 450 percent
government debt is over 70 percent and
in turkey government debt to gdp is in
the 80 to 90 percent range
the way most analysts evaluate
sustainability of government debt
often produces too optimistic a
conclusion
that is because it doesn't pay enough
attention to the foreign exchange
constraint
in economies like argentina and brazil
where exports only account for ten
percent of gdp
about a sixth of the ratios for average
emerging economies
and a half or a third of the ratios for
chile and mexico
this analysis also fails to give enough
emphasis
to the large negative feedback effects
of high real interest rates
and fiscal policy contraction on
economic growth
as well as to the effect of falling
government bond prices on the balance
sheets of emerging market banks
which hold the bulk of these bonds let
me illustrate some of these points by
reference to the brazil
situation in the middle of june i was
asked by several brazilian newspapers
about the probability of brazil having
to do a major debt restructuring by end
2003
i said then i thought the probability
was about 70
and even with the 30 billion imf rescue
package
i continued to believe that that number
is in the right ballpark
why not why isn't the rate in the
probability 90 or 95 percent
well brazil clearly has strengths that
argentina didn't have
it has a competitive floating exchange
rate sensible monetary policy regime of
inflation targeting
its banks are better hedged against
currency depreciation
the public sector has run primary
surpluses of three and a half percent of
gdp for three years running
and its current policy makers especially
governor fraga are pragmatic and highly
experienced in crisis management
that said why then is the probability of
default not 30
percent of 70 well contrary to what you
often hear
brazil does have some weak fundamentals
growth slowdowns are bad for debt
sustainability
brazil is likely to grow this year by
one percent the average growth rate over
the past five years was two percent
half of brazil's exports go to the u.s
euroland and japan
the consensus forecast for those three
areas this year
are about two and a half percent one
percent and minus a half respectively
another quarter of those exports go to
latin america
which excluding brazil will perhaps grow
by minus three percent this year
growth forecast for 2003 and brazil's
export markets are somewhat better but
are being downgraded
last week morgan stanley's chief
economist steve roach
gave a talk here at the ie where he
argued that the risk of a double dip
recession in the u.s
over the next nine months was about 50
percent the bottom line is that brazil
is not facing a growth-friendly
environment over the next six to nine
months
when the confidence game is to be won or
lost
if they had a five-year grace period
maybe they can reach their potential
growth
of four percent but not in the next year
the external interest rate spread on
brazil's benchmark bonds is currently
about 2 400 basis points
about where it was before the
announcement of the imf package
they need to get that down to below a
thousand basis points
to obtain single digit real interest
rates reducing it to sixteen hundred or
fourteen hundred basis points wouldn't
help much
overnight to one year rates in brazil
are running in the range of eighteen to
twenty seven percent
as george suggested with a six or seven
percent inflation rate
you're talking about very high real
interest rates they have some debt that
they
contracted at lower interest rates in
the past but it's not big enough
40 of the public debt is tied to the
exchange rate and because the real is at
an
all-time low of 388 the central bank
doesn't have much room
to lower interest rates if they lower
interest rates and the exchange rate
falls further
the public debt ratio rises and the risk
premium increases
lula is way ahead of sir in the polls
and is likely to win in either the first
or second rounds
even if the pt has shown that they are
not fiscal spend thrifts
lula is likely to have a tough time
talking the talk markets want to hear
he has said he won't reappoint frogger
to the central bank
why i don't know that he'll use these
state-owned banks or the sobs as i like
to call them
to build infrastructure that he'll go
slow on privatization and trade
liberalization and they'll hike minimum
wages what about future primary
surpluses
i don't think it means much that the
presidential candidates all pledge to
support
uh a three and three-quarter percent
surplus and to honor contracts
former minister for cavallo promised
never to devalue and default
in the end the argentines had to do both
prime minister kazumi pledged the host
of fiscal and financial sector reforms
he has done practically none of them
circumstances after the election are
what counts
the next brazilian congress will
probably have a party representation
similar to this one
how easy then to increase the primary
surplus to five to six percent of
gdp nobody is even talking about going
beyond four percent
if they were maybe you could be more
hopeful whoever wins the brazilian
presidential election
the debt will still be there as i
pointed out in the financial times op-ed
that's in your packet
brazil's net public debt as a share of
gdp
in 1994 was 30 today
it is over 62 and not even one of the
past
eight years did this ratio decline is
this the kind of fiscal and debt
management
behavior that we want to hold up as a
model for emerging economies
brazil faces external financial
requirements next year 40 to 45 billion
we've got substantial g7 investor risk
conversion
with sharply declining their private
capital flows those g7 investors who
want to cross
over to emerging markets may prefer to
go to china south korea mexico chile and
yes russia
where vulnerabilities are lower and
prospects better
the current account brazil is indeed
improving 15 or 16 billion this year and
as opposed to 20 or 25 that people
thought earlier
but the improvement in the current
account reflects a large fallen import
value
larger fallen import value than an
export value and is being driven by very
weak economic activity
and a very weak exchange rate if the
economy did rebound to three or four
percent next year
and if the real did appreciate back to
say 275
as the debt sustainability optimists
expect
then the current account improvement
would disappear or get much smaller
foreign direct investment still likely
to come in about 50 percent
this year in the next of the 2000 level
much of it represents
forced conversion of debt into equity
capital flight is on the rise and the
agreement
with banks on short-term credit lines is
a weak one to sum up
in my heart i hope brazil makes it but
my head tells me
that it faces long odds in avoiding a
debt crisis over the next 15 months
when you have too much debt it's
difficult to solve the problem by taking
on more debt
with a primary surplus of three and a
half to four percent of gdp
you need to keep the difference between
real interest rates and real growth
rates down to six or seven percentage
points
i don't think prospects are good for
doing that if brazil
did have to restructure it would be
messy the economy may contract by say
five percent next year and there would
be considerable strains in the financial
sector
because brazilian banks are holding
about bonds worth about 300 percent of
net worth
but with good policies a cooperative
approach to predators a lower debt
burden and some ifi support i believe
brazil could gain healthy economic
growth in the medium term
what does all this mean for the future
and the behavior of the ifis
and policymakers four quick points
to begin with i don't see anything in
recent financial crisis to suggest that
the market model for emerging economies
should be discarded neither argentina or
brazil got into trouble because they
were too open to foreign banks
or because they privatized too much that
because they weren't protectionist
enough in their trade policies the
origin of these crises had to do with
fiscal policy excesses
and poor debt management over a long
period and in argentina's case
with holding on to the wrong currency
regime for too long
if latin america draws the lesson from
recent crises
that it should turn away from the market
or blame the imf for most of its
troubles
it will make a very costly mistake
second the imf and other ifis need to be
more forceful
in advising emerging economies to be
more conservative
in accumulating and managing public and
external debt
when you get these government debt to
gdp ratios is 60 percent
or so and external debt to merchandise
exports are four or five hundred percent
you're looking for trouble likewise
emerging economies
have left themselves hostage to fortune
when they denominate or link so much of
the debt to the exchange rate
when they let the maturity of debt get
too short and when they encourage
banks and other financial institutions
to hold so much government debt on their
balance sheets
if friendly and confidential advice
doesn't have any impact
the fund should be more public and
drawing attention to these debt
vulnerabilities
when they're on the rise third debt
sustainability has to become a core
condition for fund financial assistance
along with realistic exchange rates and
discipline micro policies
if the fund continues to supply large
rescue packages
the countries with unsustainable debt
positions the imf will ultimately incur
large arrears
the indebted countries will frequently
be on the edge of crisis and they will
not resume healthy growth
i want to emphasize that i am not saying
that debt restructuring is our defaults
are low cost or can be surgically
implemented with little consequences
debt restructurings do harm to creditors
market to countries market access
to their institutions their internal
credit culture
and to their financial systems but the
argument for debt restructuring is not
that it is costless
it is instead that an inevitable debt
restructuring is less costly now than a
larger one six months or a year down the
road
after the authorities have gambled for
resurrection and incurred heavy costs
trying to defend the indefensible
in a similar vein the relevant choice
will increasingly not be
between supplying large imf rescue
packages
with no restructuring or doing a
restructuring with no imf money
instead it will be to figure out how a
moderate imf financial assistance can be
combined with debt restructuring
to put the country back on a sustainable
growth path
i'm in favor of the collective action
clauses and the sdrm
but neither of those will get very far
until the imf is ready
to ask for debt restructuring as a core
condition last point
g7 or imf guarantees designed to
increase net capital flows to emerging
economies and to lower interest rate
spreads
are not the answer as we saw in the
run-up to the asian crisis
large net capital flows in the absence
of adequate risk management on the part
of both borrowers and lenders
is a recipe for increased crisis
vulnerability
not salvation the imf 40 has huge
exposure to several highly indebted
emerging economies
including argentina brazil and turkey
and if those economies do not repay on
time
both the functioning of the imf and its
support from creditors will be severely
impaired
given that there are real risks and
lending to brazil this is not the time
to go double or nothing
when brazil's debt is reduced to a
sustainable level and the new government
makes sensible policy recommendations
capital will come back into brazil again
in larger amounts
what we have here is a failure of some
important countries in the system
not a failure of the system itself there
are no painless shortcuts to overseeing
the
overcoming the crisis in latin america
let me stop here
morris thank you uh as many of you know
in the early years of the institute we
usually presented a fairly consistent
view
on individual topics we still do that
sometimes
but now we've expanded our staff and so
we've become in some cases a one-stop
shop
where you can get all points of view on
the same topic and i now turn to john
williamson for an alternative approach
on brazil
john well thank you very much fred i am
indeed going to focus
uh primarily almost exclusively on
brazil
and uh in particular give you an
alternative view
to uh that which maurice has just
presented to you
let me assume that uh one week from now
uh president-elect lula is uh
considering
his economic options and there are
clearly going to be
uh there's going to be one dominant
decision for him whether to
go quickly for a debt restructuring and
the manner just recommended by
morris or whether to try and tough it
out without doing that
and it's not the only decision you'll
have to make clearly a little bit
decisions about things like capital
controls as well
but that's going to be a key uh
decision uh in june of this year
the um the the coalition
between the peter the the workers party
and its allies in the election and it
does have allies in the election it's
not a one-party
ban uh issued a policy statement in
which they declared quite categorically
that they
intended to regard uh contracts
as uh sacrosanct
um as uh marissa said you that
those statements are not always
they can't always be fulfilled
but nevertheless that was a quite clear
commitment
uh one also could look at the record of
the pete
in state and municipal government in
brazil
where it has not been inclined to
go back on uh contracts
and it seems to me that uh if one takes
those sorts of considerations into
account
then it is highly unlikely that if the
markets were offering offering brazil
anything like normal terms that uh
the government new government would be
considering any type of
debt moratorium standstill
restructuring what i mean by normal
terms
something like an interest rate on found
out of three or four hundred basis
points over libor
uh an exchange rate of uh two and a half
hay ice to the dollar
that's the most depreciated rate that i
have seen any investment bank
uh estimate to be an equilibrium rate
those sorts of terms clearly brazil
would not be thinking
of a default but as i argue in the
policy brief that you also have in your
pack
brazil is in a situation of multiple
equilibria at the moment
given normal market terms the debt is
manageable
given the maintenance of the current
terms it isn't
the decision that a lula government will
therefore have to make
is whether to try to persuade the market
to change its views
and that is not a hopeless task it has
been accomplished from time to time in
the past
mexico in 1995 was perhaps the most
uh conspicuous recent example
but joyce chang did a a little table
recently in which she looked at the
countries
uh which had where where
sovereign risk had gone where the the
uh this fed had gone over 2000 basis
points
and she found that in the majority of
cases countries had come back from the
brink without going through a debt
restructuring
and if i can go a little bit further
back in history early in my career i
entered the british treasury
at a time when there was a labor
government that a few months before had
devalued the pound and the financial
markets were still
going berserk every time there was a bit
of bad news with a great speculative run
against the pound
because they were convinced that there
was a second devaluation coming
now in fact the macroeconomic
fundamentals had been put in place where
a second devaluation
was not necessary i thought that was
pretty obvious but the market didn't
and it was another eight months before
the market
recognized that that was not going to be
necessary
so these things can sometimes work out
where there is a government that is
determined to
tough it out of course it will take time
i think there's no question about that
of course also it will require the new
government to
put together successfully a coalition in
congress
which is able to get support for tax
reform
without which the fiscal the primary
fiscal surplus will not remain
in excess of three and three-quarter
percent of gnp
uh it also will need to tackle social
security reform very early
because at the moment under the
brazilian social security
system the um uh
how much everybody is entitled to is
expressed in multiples of the minimum
wage
i was when i first went to brazil
and was offered a job it was for salary
of 28 minimum wages well you get the
same sort of thing
people get umpteen minimum wages as
their pensions
and if lula really wants to double the
minimum wage in four years then he has
to get a reform of the
social security system to break that
link early on
quite possibly it would also be
necessary to
go for yet a further increase in the
primary surplus
i think and that suggests that growth is
unlikely
to be rapid in brazil next year under
any circumstances i think
uh mike moosa's bimodal distribution
that he has in the
paper averaging on zero is optimistic
i think there is indeed a possibility of
a very negative outcome
but if if the government
gets by without a a debt restructuring
i still don't see that as being rapid
growth in the next year or two
i see that as a period when the
government needs to
build its credibility including with the
financial markets
and thereby create a situation where
it would be able to achieve more rapid
growth in the year or two
after that before the end of its mandate
now clearly that conclusion that there
won't be
any rapid return to growth will be
difficult
for the petta and particularly the
radical wing of it maybe a third of the
party
to swallow but the question has to be
asked what's the alternative
and here we come to malice's alternative
of debt reconstruction
and there are three options of this
one is to reconstruct the domestic debt
and not the external debt and i don't
think anyone's considering that
a second is to do the external debt and
not the domestic debt
and the third is to do both of them and
morris hasn't been explicit but i take
it that he's talking about
doing both of them but let me spend just
a moment
on the possibility of having an external
debt reconstruction
without an internal debt reconstruction
about 20 percent of the total debt
uh is in his external debt
and so if you and about half of that
is to the ifis the world bank and imf
etc
so that if one and
debt is about 60 of gnp so that if one
were to recons
if one were to to halve the value of the
external debt which seems to be what the
market is expecting
uh there that would result in saving
uh in reducing the debt to gdp ratio
from sixty percent to fifty seven
percent by three percent
right fifty percent of fifty percent of
twelve percent
uh and that really wouldn't be
uh uh a a great deal of difference
and moreover you'd have to reckon that
part of the benefit of that would
probably
be lost through a rising interest rates
um why are interest rates in brazil
so high why why have they been in
in not just in double digits but way up
20
and more for for decades
surely it is because brazil has
historically made a habit
whenever it gets into trouble of doing
exactly what morris is recommending now
and cutting the debt and even if that
were restricted to the external debt i
imagine that there would be an
impact on interest rates
so there would clearly be a very modest
budgetary impact
i don't think the balance of payments
impact would be terribly important
because
there is a a major improvement in the
current account that is in process
and i don't think that that has
concluded
yet uh export volumes incidentally have
been
increasing its export values that have
been decreasing
because prices have been very weak uh
coffee is still a big brazilian export
and does it
at its lowest level for a coffee price
for 100 years or more
um and that that feeds into uh
the the picture uh
i think that the
forecasts for the trade balance that you
get
uh coming through the all the investment
banks at least when i last looked a
couple of weeks ago
seemed to me to be incredibly small they
they were for
the trade surplus edging up from its
level
expected level this year of seven to
eight billion dollars to maybe
nine billion dollars next year
now if you that still implies
a uh a major it in my
my piece i said looking at the trends
i thought something like 15 billion
trade surplus was more likely
that still implies the current account
deficit but in fact
brazil announced its first current
account surplus for
for the most recent month for the first
time since uh
1994 so that even my forecast
implies a worsening from where brazil is
now
i think the uh the count account
improvement
is much better than has been
generally recognized and of course the
final objection to doing just the
external debt
is that the foreign creditors would
object
after all if they swallowed it it would
be
very easy for any other country in the
future to restructure its fund that
without doing
domestic debt and that i think
would not be an acceptable situation to
foreign creditors so
they would pursue all the legal
stratagems that the sdrm is intended to
prevent but that are not yet prevented
so let me consider the possibility of
doing both parts of the debt
uh doing the domestic debt as well which
is uh
which is 80 percent of the total 48
percent of gdp
roughly well the banks hold about a
third of that domestic debt and as
uh morris has already said if that were
to be
restructured the uh banks would have to
be bailed out
and how would they be bailed out well by
finding small government bonds so you
get no
net impact on government debt so let's
assume that the debt held by the banks
would not be
restructured if
in that case the um
uh the the if and if you had a 50
cut in the the uh
value of the domestic debt that would be
worth something like 16 percent
of the debt gdp ratio in other words
the two parts together would get you
down to
a debt export ratio of something over 40
percent
uh if even if the banks were exempted of
course there'd be enormous
damage to the rest of the financial
system that indeed there'd be a whole
series of ill effects which
uh morris mentioned apart from the
chaos of resulting from those impacts
a debt restructuring would administer
a large deflationary shock to the
economy
after all if you take 16 percent out of
the wealth of invest
16 of gdp from the wealth of investors
uh they're unlikely to cons continue
spending at the same rate and that's how
one gets
the uh probability of a
recession of something like a five
percent bias estimated
instead of the four percent growth that
the the pet
is aiming at uh the the other point to
remember
is that if the peta came in and was
immediately
associated with a financial crisis
that than its full course like this
it would surely make the party
unelectable
again for the next decade and then even
when it finally came back if it did come
back one day
it would still have to go undergo that
difficult process
of earning market acceptability that the
british labor party
went through in the late 1960s every
left-wing party that comes to office has
to face up to
that difficulty at some stage in its
history
and to simply push it off by doing a
debt restructuring the short run
seems to me doesn't help interest rates
as i've already argued would stay
high after a debt restructuring because
everyone would assume that sooner or
later
it was going to be another so if one
weighs costs versus benefits uh yeah
sure toughing it out will be difficult
in the short run
but i think it makes sense in the long
run especially
ironically because if lula were in fact
to become president and were to
re-establish
credibility with the market the fall in
interest rates that would then be
possible
would be much greater than anything that
jose seja
could expect to produce the reason being
that one reason interest rates have
stayed high in brazil
is the fear that there's this bogeyman
in the wings who's going to
main be not be there this time but is
going to win an election in three or
four years time
and come in and expropriate everybody
well if
once there was a demonstration that that
didn't happen seems to me one could
expect
interest rates to fall and in that way
the present primary surplus would be
quite adequate
to turn to good debt dynamics i really
am not very impressed by
sort of what i call hermann khan debt
dynamics
you know you look at a trend and you
extrapolated into the future and
you say in his case it was japan would
be so much
have bigger gnp than the united states
by the year 2000
and in morris's case it's you know
debt to gdp has been rising and so it's
going to go on rising
you have to look behind the figures to
ask whether that's likely or not
now yeah my fed is telling me i'm a
stopper i was just going to say
that much as i might like brazil to get
the sort of
assistance that soros has stopped talked
about
i think we have to we have to
reason on the likelihood that that is
not going to happen
and hence the the best it seems to me
that one can hope for is that a lula
government will decide to tough it out
and will show the skill that is needed
to make that work
okay thanks to all three of you paul do
you want to say anything on this
i don't think so i i was going to buy
brazilian bonds when i was listening to
george and then they sold them all when
i was listening to
morris and they don't know where i am
now
all right well with that degree of clear
advice to the audience we'll open the
floor for comment
uh ted truman just to add to the
internal iie debate well i just thought
that
john is interesting john was to the
conservatives obviously he didn't buy
into george's proposal
and indeed he didn't mention anything
about any international support
and is that because he thinks that he's
not going to lula's not going to get it
doesn't deserve it uh or why not uh
for example if if you think that the
modal estimate of
of growth next year in in brazil is
minus two why shouldn't there at least
be some international support to
to deal with the cyclical adjustment
problem associated with the uh
with the uh budget deficit in
a budget position in brazil some
additional financing
uh so that that that amounts of bail
bonds did not have to go in the market
and then you essentially use the imf or
the world bank which i've always
obligated
in this circumstances to uh to help to
question this
question the size of the fiscal
adjustment that would be necessary
uh so you don't get yourself into the
diamond debt dynamics
that you did get it seems to me in
argentina so where is the rest of the
world john and maybe with something in
terms of helping with this uh
this very bad cisco and this uh
cyclical impact you anticipate already
would be uh
impacting on the fiscal deficit
well i i've taken for granted that the
quite substantial imf package that has
already been announced will be available
assuming that the
uh debt condition the the
fiscal surplus is indeed maintained the
primary fiscal surplus
at the agreed level um should one go
beyond that and make even more available
um frankly i i mean
i would love it if we lived in that sort
of world but it doesn't seem to me that
uh we're likely to see that and also i
think that probably it
is true that salvation is only going to
come to lula if he
convinces the financial markets and that
borrowing more at this stage
would probably not be
it it wouldn't help in that
so it's good i think it's good that what
is there
is there i'm not one of these fanatics
for
minimizing imf support packages i can't
see what we
already the size of the imf is very
small compared with what it was
conceived as when it was first created
and i don't see any need to confess it
further
but on the other hand i'm not sure that
a a further big package
would really resolve the problem paul
i don't want to interrupt this
conversation on brazil which i don't
know much about
but i am intrigued and not surprised by
george soros's basic point which i
summarized here financial markets are
inherently unstable i don't think
there's any question about that
the international financial system is
lopsided in favor of the center into the
detriment of the periphery
and if that's true it's a very profound
and difficult
statement i would
state it somewhat differently but i
think his statement i will accept
uh as an approximation and i think
that's what we ought to be concentrating
on
brazil may be one example it's
my mind it's a particularly difficult
example because brazil is a big and kind
of inherently more stable country
than some of the other countries on
periphery that
should be more vulnerable
but if this is true we got a
structure of a systemic problem that we
haven't faced up to
george you want to uh elaborate well
you know to stick to brazil because
that's the issue and i
very much appreciate your comments and i
hope that we
we can discuss the larger issue
to default or not to default that's the
question
and if i were lula i would put that
question
to the international financial
authorities because
without an assurance that the
that credit will be available at not
more than
10 percent actually the calculation
is in favor of doing it sooner rather
than later
so in this respect i i agree with a bit
morris
but i disagree with morris is that uh
it's not up to brazil
to follow sound policies uh
not to you know better debt management
i mean it's like marie antoinette saying
you know let them eat
cake if brazil doesn't have the
opportunity
to borrow at reasonable rates so it
has to be a systemic change making rates
making money available
now it is then really up to the uh the
um the imf for the authorities behind
the imf which is basically the treasury
uh to to decide whether
uh brazil should default or not
if they they want brazil to pay
they could make money available as
lender of last resort
but the current thinking is very much
against that
and i'm i'm sure that they they
they won't do it in which case they're
basically for
forcing brazil to default i think
it won't hurt brazil all that much
down bleeding away slowly would hurt
them a great deal
more than taking the bull by the horn
and and facing because brazil is a large
economy
and it has a primary surplus it has a
trade surplus
so actually i think it would survive
very well
i think globalization as we know it will
not survive
and that's the problem fred if i could
just add a quick word
uh i think the question is not so much
whether the international financial
institutions are going to help
countries like brazil i think they
should the question is under what
conditions and will it be effective in
august of
2001 they provided a loan to argentina
without asking them to change the
exchange rate and without
asking them to restructure the debt and
that proved
not to be effective it was a big mistake
and now the fund is contemplating giving
a loan to argentina simply to get the
money
that has lent previously uh uh back
so i'm not i don't mind giving money to
brazil
i think as long as it's going to be
effective and i think
uh the money would have to be defined be
combined with a debt restructuring
not because i think that's an appealing
prospect but because i think without it
it's too unlikely that they can get back
on their feet
also reference to john's uh
argument i think it's not so much
whether they can decide
to tough it out the question is will the
markets
buy what they're selling otherwise
there'll be capital flight bank runs and
trouble in the auctions and the thing
will
will blow up so that's the
they can decide to a certain extent but
at some point the market as it did in
argentina
will force the game and and the question
is in that relevant period
will lulu be able to put forth policies
that will convince people that this is
in fact
sustainable i would be pleasantly
surprised if
he is able to do so right now i just
don't rate that very highly given
what i think we can expect uh in the
world and
uh uh from uh earlier statements uh
and the like but it's it's really i
think not a question of support or no
support whether the periphery
gets support is a question of under what
conditions will that support be
effective
when are we deceiving ourselves about
the success of it and when not
and if we make a big mistake are we
going to see the imf there with
very large arrears and is that is going
to be a problem too
okay can i just say i mean i agree with
george
about the that there is a real systemic
problem
that there is a real systemic problem
that
the conditions are not there to maintain
the international capital market in the
way it's functioned over the last
20 years or so i think that's going to
force a
uh reconsideration of
the international capital market much
less uh
uh mobility in the form of bonds of
medium-term bank lending that type of
thing um
but where um well i think there's
there's a real uh difference between
argentina and brazil
is in terms of whether existing
strategies offer the possibility of an
out or not and in in argentina
i couldn't see how with a fixed exchange
rate and a budget deficit
that every year
had to be to be reduced further
there simply was no way in which one
could see an economic recovering
recovery coming about in the case of
argentina
in the case of brazil it seems to me
it's entirely different it's a very
competitive
exchange rate um the the trade surplus
is responding as one would expect
those and the sort of bleeding
is is this is internal debt payment
primarily i mean the external debt is
not a major part of the problem
in brazil so it's for those reasons that
i think one should draw a very sharp
distinction
between the type of situation that one
had in argentina and the type that one
had in brazil
and it makes sense to try and
avoid a debt reconstruction in the
brazilian case
well each of the speakers has now had a
final word
where already past our witching hour of
5 30 which i promise to close
so i will call the proceedings to a hall
we would invite you to join us
on the patio and in the back for some
refreshments if you would like to
continue the discussion further
we thank you for coming and we look
forward to seeing you again in the near
future
okay